اوروبا قاره الرفاه والاستقرار يغير
المستهلك فيها الان سلوكيات انفاقه للتالم
مع غلاء المعيشه منظر طوابير وطلبات
الانضمام لبنوك الطعام اصبح منتشره هناك
في اكبر اقتصادات اوروبا الطعام في هذه
البنوك ليس مجانيه لكنها تحاول توفير
انواع مختلفه باسعار مخفضه معتمده على عمل
المتطوعين والتبرعات من محلات السوبر
ماركت في بريطانيا بات الملايين يفوتونا
وجبات الطعام بسبب غلاء المعيشه بحسب
استطلاع عن خير اكبروا شبكه لبنك الطعام
في بريطانيا كشفت ان زياده الزائرين الجدد
وصلت ل 40% عن العمل
حيث سجل الطلبات للانضمام للحصول على
خدمات بنوك الطعام
بحوالي 50% مقارنه بالعام الماضي
وحتى في اسبانيا تقول المنظمات الانسانيه
انها تستقبل زياده قدرها 10 اسر اسبوعيا
بعد ان كانت تغطي فقط العاطلين عن العمل
[موسيقى]